[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome to the creek in the cave
a few things before we get started
please stay off your cell phone snow
heckling and keep table talk to a
minimum
now who's ready to see other people
we'll give it up for the host who's a
dating expert he's going to get you to
that level to be good at dating too it's
hans kim
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for coming out my
name is hans kim and we are gonna date
tonight
finally after years of celibacy
my name is hans kim and uh
this is my dating show uh i pulled two
names out of the bucket and then we
watched two people go on a date for one
minute and then afterwards we make fun
of the things that they thought would be
sexy to say on stage
and we make them feel really really bad
about who they are
as a person
no just kidding this is a very positive
show
uh
hopefully we have some lgbtq names
we still have yet to have a lgbt thing
it might be the texas
politics you know but it's not really
about politics it's about uh sex and
other people
so we're gonna have fun
if you haven't signed up please sign up
the more the merrier
but
we always have a guest on this show and
tonight's guest is a very funny comedian
she's a local here in austin please get
up for the very funny mars g
[Applause]
hey mars how are you doing hi i'm doing
good how are you i'm doing so fantastic
i actually went on a date and
had a full intercourse recently
congratulations thank you
anyways
um
there is a bottle cap on the uh
the table which is kind of annoying you
know i thought uh
sam would take care of that sam's a
cameraman give it up for sam he's gonna
be filming this
[Applause]
we got a whole bunch of people in here
um
hopefully one of you uh will get up here
uh we only got these two in the front
row brave men
horny horny brave men
trying to get up on stage quicker
but yeah
it's a good good sized audience tonight
so hopefully there will be a lot of
raucous laughter
and a lot of sexual tension tonight
should be a good one
for the uh man we have jeremiah price
coming up on stage
jeremiah
here he comes
and he's gonna go on a date with a
beautiful woman called pooja
[Music]
she's uh smoking weed apparently
or on the toilet
here comes pooja
fresh from a smoke break
complete this way
she's too high she doesn't know where
she is right now
either that or
she pinched out a big loaf
give it up for this morning um
we mostly ate and drank
what are you drinking what are we doing
beer
what kind of beer
i actually drink cider
i'm not a beer person same here
uh angry workers the way to go boston
but they don't have that out here just
uh us e-cider
it was good i liked it yeah pretty good
how much longer we got
birthday you came out here for girls
what's going on here
no no birthdays it's just a long weekend
i'm in school i had a long like i had
the monday off so it was a nice time to
get away
give it up for jeremiah
[Applause]
you're gonna need to come back
we're gonna talk to you now
apparently jeremiah was so bad that puja
wanted to run away immediately
that was a nice interrogation slash date
uh you got a record 17 questions out
an amazing record
uh so you're from new jersey yeah and
how long are you here for
we leave tomorrow morning nice
how do you like austin so far it was
nice it was a little cold honestly like
the first two days we were here was
freezing but going out on rainy was fun
uh-huh
and uh jeremiah if you were to take puja
anywhere in austin to show her the true
austin culture where would you take her
dang i just got here so
what do you mean i saw you three weeks
ago
i know
it has been i haven't done much
exploring um 20 minutes from hoboken i'm
in this place called nutley that's where
we see
that's what jeremiah was thinking about
the whole time it was up here
mars what do you think about this
wonderful couple you think they have a
future
i mean if you're comfortable with
jeremiah not being a one-woman man
because he was on a date with me two
weeks ago
whoa
this is some soap opera drama
i pimp him out is it'll be 17 an hour
for a jeremiah if you guys want to
really remember austin that's cheap
um it's a living wage
so uh you had beers you're you have
you're not that into beers or you're
you're like ciders yeah i don't like
beers that much nice
so
do you uh you like you like beers that
taste like juice
yeah i do that's cool jeremiah are you a
big big drinker
i am yeah
nice usually
looking usually whiskey or ciders
actually both at the same time
you could take her to cider
cider kid's a good one
yeah i love sarcade it's uh you get a
bunch of
smorgasbord of ciders and you play games
and like
i don't know all kinds of video games
mostly
pretty cool it's a little arcade
yeah jeremiah
looks like he'd be
really into
nerdy stuff
but also has the body to tackle someone
so you get the best of both worlds with
jeremiah
puja do you play so
we're gonna have to edit this part out
thank you yeah it's pretty much the
exact same pizza you can get in hoboken
so uh what are you uh what is your
dating life like is there a lot of new
jersey men that uh you know you you're
seeing or have you been dating in new
jersey with a lot of like these guidos
and douchebags
um no pretty non-existent
oh
that sucks that's my reaction too
uh you're uh indian do you uh have in
traditional indian parents
no they're not that traditional they're
untraditional they're just like [ __ ]
shooting off guns and
cursing
cursing
they're they're in the middle they're
like americanized yeah it's the best
kind i think of uh immigrant
no just kidding my parents are also
asian
[Laughter]
jeremiah where are your parents from
uh the congo
wow
they're from
texas and colorado what the [ __ ] are you
trying to make me look racist
[Laughter]
so you're american
yes absolutely
just like puja's parents
you guys can have a lot to talk about
mars what do you think about this uh
immigrant couple i guess he's american
so
how many kids are y'all thinking of
having isn't that like a first
conversation for for immigrant couples
oh
yeah
when's the wedding date
two two yes two here we go she's with it
thank you for continuing the public
population growth of this country
um
what uh what kind of gender do you think
these kids would be
or sex
what kind of what what boy girl
combination would you like to raise
together and then boy
and then girl
maybe if they're gender fluid they can
swap
why why do you want a girl first
um i had an older brother and i just
like to see the opposite i think it'd be
better that way oh yeah let's see
something different you're bored you're
like oh let's make my kids live my
fantasies
uh it's a large part of parenthood and
jeremiah why do you want a boy first i
was older sibling and i think it turned
out okay damn so you're the opposite of
puja you're like my [ __ ] rocks let me
let me make more of me
puja's like
i want to experiment
we need to switch things up we can do a
test tube baby
you get exactly what you want you want
blue eyes got you
um
this is a beautiful couple
we got an african-american and an indian
so
he can open up a 7-eleven in the hood
and
he'll have street cred
store but uh yeah i mean uh i think that
you guys have a lot of good business
sense you guys both seem smart and
responsible what do you do for a living
pooja i'm a med student oh of course
you're indian
your parents must be very proud
unfortunately they're not traditional so
they're like oh you're not an artist
boring
you're not
you're not furthering
our culture
um no you're doing great med student
you're uh you're so you're in undergrad
still no i'm in medical school now oh
nice
yeah i have no idea how that works i'm a
bad asian it's not that great
wow
what kind of medicine do you want to
specialize in
um i like cardiology right now but i'm
in my first year so i still have time to
hide oh a heart doctor
it's a good good one to date she she can
fix your heart after she breaks mine
you can take my i don't think that's too
good for you
she can give you a heart transplant
jeremiah what do you do for a living
property management
nice
so you can have a place to live
she can fix you up you don't even have
to leave the house
that you bought
jeremiah um have you ever dated a doctor
before
i have not no well you still have it
she's pre-med
she's not successful yet
how much debt do you have
[Music]
that's tough um
if only your parents were traditional
and could pay for your school oh
probably like 400 okay 400k
peppa pepiro
nice
i hope you're good at real estate
so uh jeremiah how much debt do you have
i'd rather not say whoa
it's
it's zero oh yeah i love that i love how
you said you'd rather not say and then
you said it right away
it just sounded worse if i didn't say it
well you're four hundred thousand
dollars richer than your date so
the patriarchy exists
uh mars uh what do you think about this
debt laden couple you think that they
can make it into the black or you think
they'll be forever destined to poverty
and
sadness you have a way of words
thanks
um
i think if you do your best at the kiosk
you know anything is possible
quit pre-med get to selling those purses
no just do a side gig you know what i'm
saying
side gig that gets four hundred thousand
dollars
at least
um
yeah i mean um solidify this
relationship what does this look like at
at 8 p.m you guys leave the creek
together holding hands
what happens
in the next 12 hours
looking at me uh jeremiah you're from
you live here
oh yeah you got me um
food for sure um there's some all you
can eat sushi places are pretty dope
um ride some scooters around check out
the town
rise of scooters around those the school
is pretty fun unstable but fun
uh
see more comedy shows it's mostly what i
do out here
so you just stuff her full of food
go for a romantic carriage ride to the
airport
ride one of those horse
police horses to the airport together
um
but most of your activities involve not
talking to each other the comedy sushi
riding bird scooters
uh which i i think would be good because
there was a lot you already asked her
all the questions you could ask her in
the one minute
uh puja what do you uh what would you
where would you take jeremiah jeremiah
was stricken with you he came to new
jersey to nut nutley
and
he's just
yeah baby yeah
[Music]
he he nutted as soon as he went into
nutley uh where would you take him and
what would you do in new jersey
oh in new jersey i'd probably take him
to new york take him to a better place
it's not that much to work with in
jersey but um
yeah we'd probably go to new york go to
a bar
some dinners
we could see a museum
you can see i mean hopefully you go
inside the museum
i feel like this is real
we're manifesting it it's gonna happen
uh give it up for jeremiah and puja the
first date
oh i thought they were gonna do a
handshake or something
no physical contact what a gentleman
uh if you want to sign up the buckets
here we uh the more the merrier uh you
want to pick a a male name and i'll pick
a female name
we got
g coming up a j i
as a female
j.i
oh there she is
she made too much noise you done played
yourself
here comes g
and the male
is
i'm going to butcher this
nicholas
civic up pacific
[Music]
he has bad handwriting he might be a
doctor with puja
[Music]
give it up for gee and
nicholas sapoglia going on a date for
one minute
how's it going
enjoying your um
for me are you enjoying your evening
uh kind of kinda
dad checks out
i actually i didn't try but i think
my friends put my name on oh this is a
blind date oh man i feel so bad for you
i'm sorry kind of exciting it's exciting
enjoying it so far yes nice awesome
welcome welcome to austin
thank you welcome to the wonderful terry
black's restaurant it's amazing
oh i just smell the peel outside yeah
it's really it's it's
yeah i know yeah everybody i never
smelled that way it's an aphrodisiac
around here
what do you do for fun
finds for workout workout okay me too i
enjoy that i should yeah
are sure
you what i should you should
no i'm sure oh i'm sure oh yeah thank
you sorry
my bad it's okay
you can try i can try uh yeah that's
that's reassuring end time
give it up for nick sapoglia and g
nick sapolia not correctly understanding
the insult that g was throwing at him
i'm a bit slow hans he's not only uh
not very strong but also a little bit of
a racist
[Music]
[Laughter]
you don't think nick works out
yeah
how can you tell with that thick jacket
on why don't you uh
shed a couple layers
show her what you're working with
i can take my jacket off really yeah
oh and he's wearing a sweater how
convenient
this is going to take forever
yeah i mean uh he looks a little beefy
you know he looks thick you know maybe
he's one of those short kings have you
heard of those short kings
okay yeah
okay indeed yeah yeah yeah i'm helping
you out nick thanks thanks i try my best
hanza's always got my back
what do you think about nick's mustache
is a sexy i guess
she guesses it's sexy yeah i guess i'll
take it incorrect guess we were looking
for
creepy or weird
oh thank you nick um so
nick and g
not the uh not the stereotypical couple
i would imagine you know
she seems like uh very cutting and
biting i think she would tear you a new
one every day would you
i'm enjoying that kind of stuff okay
sweet all right i'm into that
and nick is really good at uh taking it
so you know maybe it would work out i'm
a natural what can i say i think it's a
workout yeah right yeah it's got very
chill vibes pretty good blind date so
far
yeah look at that look at that smile
yeah she's kind of having a good time
and she smells pee outside so it's a
good date
uh what did you mean by you smell pee
outside did you mean
yeah i can smell really
urinate it smells oh yeah oh that's the
homeless people yeah yeah we uh
we don't like to talk about it but
that's hoboken pies
they cook their pizzas with piss but
really
this is going out on the internet we're
going to be sued for defamation
um
but yeah i mean
we do have a healthy homeless population
here in austin where are you from gee
i'm actually living in houston before
but i moved back to the minnesota and
just got back here nice so nice austin
yes nice that's the strong minnesota
accent that we're hearing
midwestern
don't you know
so uh the p smell shouldn't be
surprising then right
it is
surprising who else noticed the pee
smell can we get a round of applause for
the p smell
nobody's raising your hands
you are a bloodhound you sniffed it out
you can help us hunt down the homeless
after this
they're all over the place we gotta
exterminate them minnesota doesn't have
it because it's just too cold they all
freeze to death yeah the pea freezes
actually it is it's really weird look at
that cold out there so
nothing smells
wonderful nice
unfortunately talking about we live in a
temperate climate so the p just floats
into the air
you said that this was terry black's is
that like a improv actually a little
improv on the improv date we just had
you know he's trying to make it seem
fancier than it was
yeah this is uh terry black's apparently
there's no p outside no none at all and
nick works out
i just said i enjoy exercising too
that's awesome
okay
nick enjoys exercising what kind of gee
what kind of exercise do you think nick
does
like a lot of
he
jazzercise
the shortest i guess yeah big shoulders
i like that see it's got a wide frame
easy to make you hug her heck yeah i'm
down with hugs
so uh if you were to hug nick would you
go for the uh
double underhooks or
no
no
the over the shoulders
over the shoulders oh that's adorable
yeah you are taller than him by about
six inches
that's the only way you guys can do it
so gee where are you from like uh
asian wise from south korea south korea
yeah
represent nice
uh you listen to k-pop or
k-pop korean pop i don't listen k-pop uh
bts
no i'm usually listening to reggaeton
reggaeton wow what a surprise
to that nick's not black i know right
story of my life
[Music]
nick what do you know about the south
korean culture
it's under north koreans culture wow for
an american that's pretty good
this is the best we're gonna get
uh i like their movies and shows movies
and shows what shows um
i really enjoyed um the new one they
just came out with we're all dead or
everybody's dead oh the zombie in high
school that one was pretty cool
parasite was really good squid games was
fun to watch you know
old boy that was a good one battle
royale is a good one too
wow
he thinks like that's a lot of violent
south korean movies
those are the ones i've seen that are
the best i know that's all we make for
some reason
uh
mars what do you think about this
interracial the second interracial
couple we've had so far
um
i think i think this has a lot of
potential
uh
yeah but i definitely think like you're
you're gonna be the dominant one here
like or they call it a dominatrix yeah
yeah they're gonna whip him and tie him
up and stuff
i'm up to new experiences i guess
[Laughter]
okay
oh
that is a modern romance right there i
can beat you
yes i can gee can you put your name into
the lgbtq bucket please
mars is
flirting at work this is workplace
harassment oh i'm so sorry
you got to be careful with that
taking sexual uh
misconduct advice from a guy with a
mustache
he's been there he's done that
that mustache doesn't grow itself
um i grow it so gee uh have you dated a
lot of uh american white
uh
white devils no i'm just kidding uh
american white men
have you dated a lot of white men before
in houston and minnesota
definitely minnesota for sure that's all
they got
no you're single in minnesota
yes
are you single now yes
nice thank you
that's good some people come up here
with relationships and it
totally levels but
yeah
do you ever call him caucasian
yeah
like to their face
no actually my teacher told me that
don't call
white whites
caucasians
blacks
don't call them black
don't say that my teacher
is kind of racist yeah just saying just
say bro
and then they'll be like oh she's asian
uh so you've dated black men before
no
okay he's just like reggaeton but you
haven't dated a black man yeah okay
that's fine nick
what races of human beings have you um
got gotten romantic with
a variety i don't discriminate
neapolitan mix have you ever dated a
south korean
not specifically south korean
north korean yeah what do you mean not
specifically south korean east west i
mean i'm sure they had um korean descent
but wasn't like a purely from the
country south korea no
that was the gong of asia
giving you the seal of approval
um so this is this would be nice like
you uh you guys both have experienced
interracial dating
um no one asked me but i've dated a lot
of white women so nice nice good for you
pretty proud of that
uh
so where would you take it would you go
get him some bulgogi or uh
or some korean dishes uh actually my
problem is i don't eat
whoa
whoa never we are really advanced beings
from the future
no i actually just eat only carrots and
cucumber
oh my god
she's on a diet
and then you exercise you you gotta work
off all those carrots and
cucumbers vitamins
nice
yeah i could pay for dinner totally then
carrots and cucumbers
yeah it's uh easy to feed her she's uh
she's low maintenance
it'd be like having a pet bunny
just gotta change the newspaper every
now and then
we probably shouldn't make jokes about
putting women in cages
so uh what do you think this guy eats
probably a lot of hamburgers and cheese
yeah i like coffee coffee is good
oh i like
i mean i don't eat it i drink it but you
know what i'm you know what i'm saying
tea is really nice i like tea as well
i like a lot a nice little lemon ginger
tea or some chamomile oh nice yeah it's
good i don't do that oh yeah
give it up for g and nick sapoglia
they're gonna drink tea together
[Applause]
i'm not just talking about the
testosterone nick is taking
to make up for his
small frame
nick sapoglia and gee wow that was that
was a great date they're both very
attractive people in my opinion
so that's good to see it doesn't
doesn't always happen
uh colton johnson is the man and he's
gonna come up and date a human female
and then the woman is
rima
rima
from the new jersey table
she's taken the ferry she's taken the
path train into
the
new york of the stage
do we got a colton johnson oh here he
comes
oh no he's going to the bathroom
colin johnson
[Music]
carlton johnson
rima is
unfortunate she's in here twice rima did
you sign up twice there's two remas
bhima and rima
you're a bema
i don't know
you're a doctor too
okay
bema
caleb ogden
where's caleb oh here he comes we know
caleb
[Music]
this is going to be a good one just
brace yourself
[Music]
where are you from where are you from
new jersey oh i yeah i got here late
yeah this is the new jersey table
oh nice you're just visiting then yes
thankfully oh thankfully you don't like
austin
man this is a rough this is a rough date
so far you know what you're not a fan of
austin
uh no austin's fine okay it's just creek
in the cave it's the bear i don't like
his hat either
oh his hat's super cute oh you think so
okay so
you got it you got to get it you know
right up there oh okay
uh so what do you do rima
i'm in like real estate
nice can you sell me house
i don't have a job you don't have a job
you can't get a house then i that's you
know that's what they tell me yeah
yeah i probably should have gotten a
house while i had a job
reverse order what was your job i used
to work in tech now i'm slightly
homeless
oh that's the pea around here
it's all me sorry whoever that was
you gotta let them know where you're at
i follow my dog right you know how dogs
mark their place oh you have a dog i do
have a dog
uh he's he's a husky he's adorable oh
that's huge
uh he's pretty small actually he's like
whip out a picture and time
let's give it up for caleb and rima
before he pulls out his dick pic
so uh
you're homeless
well not yet but i'm well on my way i'm
well on my way okay he's okay
you don't like big dogs
you uh
you do you have a parents in the health
care industry no
okay
they're they're all in real estate yes
nice
you're like the indian trumps
dad's favorite person
whoa
the rare indian trump supporter what do
you mean the only one all of the indian
dads are trump supporters i don't think
you know that oh yeah modi
oh yeah
he's like the indian trump it's like the
same thing nice it's good that there's
more trumps out there
spreading all over the world
so uh
rima what is the number one rule in real
estate
um have money have money
damn it money and a job
is it real estate your job yes you also
sell purses at the mall kiosk
no you just do real estate not in my
free time
um i thought it was location location
location but
i'm sure money is good too
yeah
caleb i think it is location location
location i've heard that too
thanks man he's kissing my ass kiss her
ass you're just trying to
i already tried to she's from new jersey
she's not even hanging out here you're
about to get on a plane flying
like how do we get you to move to austin
that's no
no
you love new jersey that much
more than austin more than austin but
i've only been here yeah the peace
smells a lot stronger there
in new york yeah
you get a mix of that vomit you know
that 2 a.m pizza vomit it's a good vibe
up there
up there in new york oh yeah the pizza
is amazing oh being a comedian it's a
bad move man well you could have told me
that two years ago you've been doing
comedy two years
well i started two years ago and then uh
i took a year off so
i just chilled and smoked so you quit
your job to do comedy then you quit
doing comedy
so now i'm a drug addict look what can
happen in america
tell us a joke
uh have you ever dated a comedian rima
red flag red flag right why why don't
you like comedians
why is that
they have no money
uh i got a bitcoin i found it once
but why are you homeless then i'll trade
it for a house you want to trade a
bitcoin for a house no
is that how things work maybe one day
rima have you ever dated a white man no
okay because that is how things work
that's what i thought g would say
she was horrified by that that question
what's wrong with white men is it the
privilege
is this normal
to be racist
what race have you dated
just indians
uh you know like native americans also
fit in or no okay
straight from bangladesh
no
not those either
oh gosh indian of a specific part of
india too it's a class system out there
it is it is for sure
yeah you got to stay within not like
here
um caleb
uh would you want to be rima's first
caucasian boyfriend absolutely wow he's
thirsty i mean it's been a minute i told
you i downloaded or i deleted tinder
he deleted tinder he's fully horny in
the moment
he can't outsource his horniness
apparently yeah it's kind of concerning
well this is my new gig this is just
peeing outside scaring away the asian
women i'm letting people know i'm here
that's my scent that's beautiful you got
a beautiful terry black scent
um
you uh you really love the bear's hat
that was that was an interesting yeah
can we take that home
you don't have enough money in new
jersey you got to steal from us poor
texans
look at this
what a carpetbagger
mars what do you think about rima and
caleb
are we a match
well rima i really want to know what can
caleb do to be your first caucasian
boyfriend literally nothing
he shouldn't be i shouldn't have quit my
job damn it
uh he has a lot of mayonnaise you can
share with you
and mustard
mustard and mayonnaise oh we love
mustard that's irregular that's how we
know i have three bottles three
wouldn't your trump loving dad love it
if you brought home a white boyfriend no
no we've been here until
since
thursday yeah okay that's a pretty quick
trip still the weekend
for the president are you afraid of
getting covered nobody has mass out here
it's all locked down up there we already
had coveted in
january they are trump supporters
that's not what i said
are you vaccinated yes wow
what a nerd
oh gosh how many vaccines how many all
three right there you go
[Music]
yeah so uh
yeah you'll uh yeah i mean that's great
uh caleb are you vaccinated
uh against polio
he doesn't like polio that's the only
one
really
i think i've had like coveted 11 times
however many variants they got i've had
them all he is homeless
caleb what do you think that you could
do to uh ingratiate yourself into the
indian american community
i don't know much about the uh indian
culture maybe you could give me a clue
she's not gonna do that maybe i could
put one of those dots on oh
kayla is that that's the only thing i
know about indian people that's the
culture
that was the last thing you should have
said i don't even know what it means
i guess it's an insult
uh yeah no what can i do to be
acceptable to the uh indian
americans be a super rich doctor
that's not going to happen
he needs a super rich doctor look how
pale he is
she's out here what would you recommend
caleb take besides vitamin d
[Laughter]
comes from the front row
and then the woman
tanya
tanya
where you at for our fourth interracial
couple
the internet's gonna love this
[Music]
get up for tonya and drew
[Music]
how's it going i'm good hey jay can you
please get a video
please video this
it's not is it on okay sorry what's your
name drew drew tonya tanya nice to meet
you nice to meet you too where are you
from portland
are you just visiting too as well
here for a wedding i'm on a four-day
binder not doing well
wait what what day of that four-day
bender are you on fourth
how are you still walking
you saw me i stumbled it wasn't good
were there strippers involved in this
weekend unfortunately no
you all are doing it wrong i know the
bat the way like come on i was the best
man and the groom canceled his bachelor
party it was your job to get the
strippers and he cancelled the bachelor
party two days before the bachelor party
that's so lame what are we gonna do
i was pissed what did y'all do instead
this weekend uh
drink
in droves
with the family and the
bridesmaids okay all right did you have
fun though yes what was your favorite
part of this weekend
in the pool in our seats in our taxes
okay that sounds like a good time yeah
it wasn't bad where are you from here
i've been here for like 23 years where
what neighborhood do you think i have
the house it's right next to the apple
campus i don't know what neighborhood
that apple cam is probably near the
domain
like tech ridge yeah
it's off of mcneil
mcneil yeah that's like the most
portland part of austin is it you're
gonna fit right in yeah there's like
perfect cars burning in the street [ __ ]
yeah
yeah as i say you guys thought your
homeless problem was bad come hang out
with us
oh we'd love to heard stories about
portland yeah i'm from seattle so hey
there you can w bros i feel bad for you
seattle sucks portland
our gdp is a lot higher than portland
true
uh but portland is great uh tanya what
do you think about portland just as a
city i've not been there but it's like
on my list of places to go
i don't know now that i met this guy i'm
not really sure
yeah try to go in between the
insurrections and the uh riots i'll try
i'll do my best riot season
yeah portland is like the austin of the
pacific northwest they're kind of weird
and literally our motto we stole it from
y'all yeah they uh keep portland they
have bachelor parties with no strippers
it's like it's very unimaginative
yeah welcome to portland
i like how you came to austin for the
bachelor isn't portland famous for
strippers and strip clubs yes
so
we have the most strip clubs per capita
in the country
it's fun it's a great time it's a great
time but it's your favorite strip club
in portland casa diablo it's the vegan
strip club you said that without me it's
a vegan strip club
bunch of where you need to go bunch of
anemic strippers half-heartedly dance
there's a strip club
that is owned by the cattle rancher and
so it's called acropolis they have steak
bites so you go acropolis is dope
[Music]
you know you know yeah you guys need to
take me to the pacific yeah it's fun
it's the land of strippers and steak and
wheat you can watch
dancers while you eat steak it's really
weird it's like your mouth isn't like
what is what's going on it's kind of
weird but uh yeah i mean um you're on a
you're on a bachelor or you're on a wet
at a wedding and uh
you didn't have a bachelor party you
came here with your bro friend
bro john
you you guys are just like
everyone else is sleeping let's go
try to date
no so it's all over we're here for the
next week just hanging out i was
supposed to look at houses all week and
i got my house on friday so i don't have
to do that anymore nice well welcome to
austin
it's a real lateral move from portland
to austin
i feel like he's moving up i think so
too yeah we have freedoms here and
cheaper rent
cheaper rent
you think austin's cheap we're very
[ __ ] yes
really 500 square foot house
19.50
people moving here from portland
jeremiah just came in his pants right
now
um
unfortunately
i uh i'm not a very good asian these
numbers are doing nothing for me
um
what made you jump in a pool with your
suit on was it for a photo shoot
no uh
i this the bridesmaid said she wanted to
do it i said don't talk about it be
about it and she said i'll do it if you
do it i said don't talk about it be
about it she ran and jumped in the pool
and it was called
well i i i gotta keep i gotta be
personally my word so there you go you
can't talk about it you gotta be about
it
was it cold
yeah the unheated pool at like 2 a.m
yeah it's been pretty cold recently
um so yeah i mean that's the kind of
stuff white people do at weddings
what kind of bender have you been on
a rough one not as hard as some of them
but molly oh no drugs no
adderall and a lot of weed and uh
way too much
adderall and a lot of weed but no drugs
adderall a lot of weed and no drugs
sorry that's that's a portland no drugs
night so sorry guys
i'm sober in portland guys so chill out
i'm just gonna detox with some weed and
adderall
what are you gonna do
so uh tanya what's like the craziest
drug you've done
all of them you've done all the
drugs all of the drugs okay we're going
to send this clip to your korean parents
i'm chinese [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you're racist as [ __ ] wow man you are
really bad you said you were a bad asian
it was actually a compliment
i was actually a compliment um koreans
are the superior asians if you insist
she will back me up
wow okay i totally thought you were
korean me backstage
okay yeah i was gonna do that anyways
uh
but yeah your chinese parents uh do they
know that you live a decadent lifestyle
uh i just don't tell them about it
well it's don't ask don't tell nice
your parents are college differential
equations difficult
multi-variable
equations
drew you're going to have to take a back
seat while tanya and i bond as asians do
it do it
i passed math 111 uh my senior year as
my last class ever failed at three math
111 that sounds very basic
you failed what failed it three times
the only class i ever failed in my life
was math 111 three times 111 not even
112. hey chill out chill out guys
it was college algebra [ __ ] college
algebra
that's like college arithmetic that's
hard
hey i'm a political scientist you guys
are mathematicians you take that it's
all right
what what uh what what did you learn in
political science like how do you
utilize that uh i was a chief of staff
for a legislator for seven years so you
made photocopies and staple things yeah
pass bills do [ __ ] like that you know
nice obvious do we know this legislator
uh no she's from oregon you wouldn't
okay probably a communist exactly
exactly quite possibly i used to work
for a congressman too which one you're
an awesome dog doggett okay
lloyd doggett i don't know enough about
texas politics but
i think that you guys will get along
what do you think about this uh
politically charged couple
yeah i mean uh
he seems sex positive she seems drug
positive i think they can really find a
fun night
in there
he just doesn't have a plug in austin i
think you wouldn't think but i do so
hit me up
so if you you said you didn't do any
drugs except weed and adderall
what drugs would you do if you were to
have like a true bender
all of them
all of them like like molly uh
those would be the main ones probably
and then whatever hallucinogens you
throw in at the end of the night to have
a nightcap
as a nightcap you really are from
portland
yeah that's yeah i don't know about that
tanya what uh what drugs do you do do
you like to do
mostly mushrooms
mostly mushrooms are great [ __ ] that's a
hell of a thing to mostly do
amazing
there they are but you got a bag of
mushrooms and let's just see you try to
convince drew to do a bunch of mushrooms
me try to convince he needs convincing
though no i don't want to do him i don't
want to do him and action
come on like you're from portland like
but i don't like the taste what are we
gonna do about that chocolate choc oh
you have mushroom chocolates
[Laughter]
so
give it up for this couple
he is an american
[Applause]
drew and tanya
they went on a date together
get up for this hippie couple they do
drugs together
let's get another couple up here
you guys ready for another couple yeah
this could be you blake barrow
we got blake coming up here from the
enthusiastic table going on a date with
miranda
miranda
[Music]
miranda
here she comes
miranda and
blake barrow
here they come to some royalty-free
music
[Music]
sounds
[Music]
hi blank
hey
who's your weed plug
oh i don't think i'm allowed to say that
who's your mushroom plug i can't i don't
i really don't think you're supposed to
say it out loud but you have both of
those
sure yeah
are you from portland too no i'm from uh
maryland okay yep
okay that's still that's so nice i think
that's really
that's really nice that you all come
together to make each other laugh
i'm not making anybody laugh tonight
yeah i hear it i hear it it feels like
it though like when you're sitting here
right
i hope so i don't know i don't know at
first you can't see people
yeah yeah
last time
you shoplifted
oh
i usually steal from whole foods that's
fine no
i'm a walgreens guy myself and time
give it up for the wet bandits
it's miranda and blake barrow
the first white couple we have up here
you're white are you serious
wow he's getting table service he really
is white
he's got the secret connection
yeah i thought it was bottle service
zach that's okay
so
um you uh
you said that uh you liked that they all
came together
uh to laugh i mean
that was last night i don't know how you
would know about that
yeah he was part of the four-day bender
he was actually the stripper that no one
ordered
if i put on a beanie you wouldn't have
no clue that i wasn't from portland
portland
all right portland fort portland fort
landworth
uh you are actually dressed like you are
from portland that was a very astute
observation thanks um are you you're
from austin or you're from maryland i'm
from maryland yeah nice yeah i'm glad
you're glad you're here away from the
murder capital
thanks yeah it's really bad right i've
been to baltimore
my brother lives in baltimore and i'm
i'm worried for him i'm just joking i
actually watched the wire that was it uh
how did you uh how did you like uh
blake
nice he's nice seems like he has a lot
of friends
your teeth are very white you have very
white teeth
i was like thank you i don't even know
what to say to that it's got a good day
thank you yeah thank you i got off meth
about six months ago and they just grew
right back
it's a success story miracle
you're from maryland that's close to
appalachia right yeah it's more i mean
unfortunately it's more like heroin and
stuff but that's getting serious yeah
she doesn't do that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that [ __ ] mess
does the real she mainlines heroin
what's the last time
when's the last time you did heroin
never i've never done heroin oh you uh
you're not from baltimore not i'm not
i'm from a suburb but what about crap
that's it never done crack you just got
your hat from a crackhead though
[Laughter]
blake what kind of drugs have you
frequented
meth yeah
right serious you did math
like six months ago so i don't
i don't like that tone
it's a kind of not a normal thing to do
not with someone with your skin
complexion i was just saying what do
white people do though i mean not like
you have very nice skin you know i
thought meth heads would have like acne
and [ __ ]
too you're one of the good ones blake
you're one of the good meth heads
it's yeah i'm a lawyer so i like uppers
yeah
so you did meth and then anytime you got
arrested differences and move back to
baltimore together
yeah okay i could see that chevy chase
sure chubby chase
the king of the suburbs chevy chase
there he is i'm super white where are
you i know where that is yeah where are
you from
fort worth
okay wow i didn't expect that i felt
like this was like real east coast sort
of hey what are you doing i'm walking
here type of energy from you
uh do you have a southern accent can you
do like a pretend you're actually from
fort worth and talk like a texas fish
yeah can you try let's hear it will you
try what if i'm from mountain brook
alabama
keep going is that close enough
okay
i've never made it this far with the
woman i don't know what to do what do i
do next they usually they've already
walked off i don't understand
can you do any other accents
not when i'm being filmed no what about
a british accent just try i thought you
were gonna ask like a korean accent to
be honest no
just close your eyes and pretend they're
not filming oh i thought you were gonna
say close your eyes
and do a korean accent
you know how long are you going to be in
austin for i could close my eyes yeah
blake you are uh being racist
blake um so you're you're from texas and
you have this high energy do you ever
like get into confrontations at the club
uh not at the club but the rodeo
obviously at the rodeo
and what do you say to the sporting
events right that's what
yeah cowboys unfortunately okay pretend
someone bumped into you now you gotta
muster all your southern aggression
and uh threaten this person
in a very calm but soothing way
use a metaphor like yeah
horses or cows
you look like you've been road hard and
put away wet
and that's okay it's not your fault me
just in general if somebody bumped me
okay oh you're you're looking hard and
wet you were looking at me
this is some of that
repressed homosexuality that texas is
famous for
i haven't seen any handsome cowboys over
here so i'm good
there's an angry cowboy in the audience
dallas buyers club over there
what do you think about what what advice
would you give this couple what do you
think this couple needs
uh drew i think uh
maybe consider going on more dates
really work out your material um
and then and then come back to this
my name is blake but i i guess yeah i
got it
drew was the last one
i'm so sorry it looks like stuck
he looks like blake but with them uh no
no mustache or facial hair y'all look
very similar i got the ball you all look
like from the same fraternity you know
yeah blend of southern tech douches that
we have here it is cool it is unique i
met a lot of different kinds of people
though
yeah southern
i work in a coffee shop so i get to see
the best of them i can't believe this to
be honest
actually i train the baristas so
wow she's she's like mean to me
she is a compliment he uh it means he
thinks that you're a feminist
i didn't know you were management so i'm
i'm into it now
my management ask him about any uh labor
disputes you have he's a lawyer he can
help oh yeah yeah you're a lawyer do you
like being a lawyer
i love it is that what you always wanted
to be
yeah i'm pretty white yeah
yeah did you ever read to kill a
mockingbird
and the sequel not very good don't read
it it's a sequel yeah yeah don't read it
it's called to revive a mockingbird
it does get pretty racist to be honest
yeah
well
so what's uh what's what's the
most ethical thing you did as a lawyer
i don't understand the question
he doesn't know about ethics
a lawyer that has no morals
uh have you like saved a woman who got
burned by hot coffee or did you uh you
know i was uh i went
i would probably go against the people
that yeah i i did defense so
i like the guy like the big corporation
nice what's the most evil company you
defended uh triple a insurance triple a
is sure
it's keeping those premiums high ladies
and gentlemen sponsored by
triple a
well
well
are you uh is there anything you can say
that will make you more likable to this
coffee
shop
employee who is clearly not
uh
lined up with your morals
you're in incredibly good sport
thanks dad
he's watched too much to kill a
mockingbird he's calling people sport
like it's the 1920s
well i thought darling would be a little
too
southern
so uh what do you think about lawyers do
you uh you think that he's one of the
good ones it's hard to tell
[Laughter]
i don't know i didn't know you could
wear jewelry if you were a lawyer
you actually are a pretty good uh judge
of character i think so too yeah
i think you're a good one you try to be
but sometimes like you think you over
you stay up late at night and you think
about the decisions you've made and i
thought you were a good georgia
character until you said i was a good
one and
no i think you're a good one i think you
really try i think you're going to
really save some people usually what i
say
yeah but i paid for a big cappuccino so
i'll just put it in a bigger cup for you
what if i made a scene you can't imagine
me making a scene about it i would have
to go to the bathroom somebody else
would have to deal with that
i can't even tell people to take their
dogs outside
i don't want to be rude you have been in
austin for a while i i get that
oh big yeah i don't really like dogs
that much
i know that's gonna not get me any
favors do you like dogs i don't like
dogs i love dogs you know i have i have
a friend that has a golden retriever
of course it doesn't work it doesn't
work for you that usually it never works
for any woman but
to have the golden retriever you use the
golden retriever for
dating purposes well not yet we've joked
about it oh okay that's cool i know his
name i've seen that i've seen that
happen like when i take walks people
they're whoring out their dogs yeah if
you see me with a dog it's not mine
but i'll lie to you i'll remember that
i'm a lawyer just yep
he's a lawyer
trust what he says lawyers lie
um that's uh sounds wonderful um you
sound like a very successful good lawyer
and it sounds like your coffee shop
might go out of business at any moment
but right it's not eats coffee is it
it's not pete's coffee no yeah it might
go out of business
yeah luckily you know a good lawyer
that's right
maybe i could do you think i could be a
lawyer absolutely cool yeah literally
cool
it let me in and it's not it's not that
hard all right that's good to know i
wasn't supposed to say that
oh okay it's super hard it's really hard
but i can do it can you lie
i can lie coming up as a man
oh here's blake again
he forgot his uh cup
john
john witherspoon is coming up
[Music]
i think
[Music]
hey it's not john witherspoon it's
second name i put in the caleb
oh you put a second name in here
you're permanently banned from the show
now
you put in a fake name
your original name is good enough dude
uh trevor
do we have a trevor in the audience
trevor is not here as well
let's get another name asian jay
i'm guessing this guy's asian
there he is asian jay
that's we already saw this person
puja did you put your name in here twice
okay the new jersey uh urban
people
remo
remo
i think this is actually our name
hopefully she's a doctor too
she's not a doctor remo and asian jay
going on a date
hello how are you i'm good is your name
really asian jay
no my friend uh tanya she decided to uh
put my name in there
but my name is jay
and i am asian
i did hear that tanya has the up on
drugs so i was looking to actually get
up here with tanya honestly but
i don't see her in the audience anymore
but i think she went to the restroom
she's coming back soon though
i'll let her know
you have the hookup as well
perhaps ably
i i i can ask around
all right that's good enough for me yeah
how uh how are you liking austin
uh it's good
it's um an oopsie
no it's been good just good food good
drinks
are you from here
no i'm uh
i'm from south korea
okay awesome yeah i'm from new york so
also not around here
so
yay let's go india
um
so how's uh how's uh austin for you like
what do you like about austin the most
uh honestly we just got drinks for like
five dollars a piece and in new york
they're like 25 so definitely the damn
that [ __ ] expensive as [ __ ]
yeah
okay okay so end time give it up for
asian jay and remo
doing what asians do best comparing
prices
how much are you paying i'm paying this
much how much are you paying
really really frugal people we are
you know you know gotta be good with
finances
yep
uh remo
you uh you're asking for a lot of drugs
i'm guessing you uh you're not a
pharmacist
no no i'm not i work in uh finance at
bloomberg
hey
we got a lawyer now we got a finance cis
i guess you're not a finance bro you're
a cis
finances
uh that's a good sorority to be a part
of
asian jay what do you do and uh how
cheap is your dry cleaning
um
i'm actually in uh tech sales
tech sales uh not the traditional asian
way to go but yeah that involves a lot
of talking it does a lot of smooth
smooth talking
so let's say that you're trying to sell
remo uh mushrooms you're trying to sell
her some technologically advanced
mushrooms let's see your uh salesman
skills at work
okay so these rooms yes
hey wow
he's an expert
so he what how old do you think he is
23
am i underestimating you go higher
28
higher
you're old as [ __ ] dude
what are you a pedophile up she's 16
relax
i'm 24 so you're in the cleveland i'm
31.
okay
he's a 31 year old asian man which is i
was surprised by the by the facial hair
that's where it was
yeah
so you guessed younger
i guess he might have just gotten it or
something yeah it's actually a surgery
you can get it in place you've got
implants you know
case your man can't grow hair
what do you can you grow a full beard
no
that's some good stubble
i get stubble but you know i can't grow
a full beard yeah you know white people
beard yeah
or indian
indian people beard
remo do you know any uh
do you like guys with beards or no no
facial hair what's your preference
say no facial hair no facial hair so
like women
i'd say we grow about the same length
compared to our faces so we're good
i hope that uh yeah i hope that your
facial hair doesn't get that bad
uh
asian jay what is uh what is your uh
daily uh
you know skincare regimen do you shave
every day
i do shave every day yup
nice you are a hairy asian man
where else do you grow hair do you have
nipple hair
um yes he has nipple hair
i have nipple hairs i gotta shade that
too i know it's
it's kind of gross gotta be aerodynamic
it's like i don't grow hair anywhere
else but my nipples it's crazy i i get i
get i get a couple pieces of hair right
here too nice
aren't indian people hairy like isn't
that a thing oh yeah i get a couple
pieces of hair there too oh
remo that's not what i meant
[Applause]
you guys can both shave each other after
the show
it'll be a bonding exercise
remo so you work in new york you work
downtown and uh you know wall street or
uh 42nd or yeah i work around uh midtown
east like central park area midtown east
wow so you do hedge fund [ __ ] or
no i'm at a mike bloomberg's company
oh yeah
mikey hey
mikey bloomberg
wasn't he the mayor for a bit
yeah yeah he was
nice
yeah he was a little racist in office
though so we we can't pack him there but
so what do you uh what do you do
financially like do you um you know buy
low sell high
yeah that's it
you summed it up i could do that that
sounds easy
asian jay what kind of tech do you sell
uh my most recent venture i sold
docusign
docusign
yeah
we've all used that before yeah
electronic signatures electronic
signatures
the way you say it
makes you want to buy it
you should definitely buy it
i'd like to sign a document to buy it
and have uh blake barrow look over it
he's a lawyer
uh so asian jay what's your dating
history like
um
well
uh i was i was married before
oh [ __ ] i went through a divorce uh
not too long ago
and i've been dating around like here
and there
did she break your heart
no
oh what a heartless bastard
he doesn't even care
no that's awesome i'm glad you moved on
from that and now you're playing the
field
like a good american
that's right
forget your korean upbringing
it's time for you to sow your seeds
that's right i gotta spread the seed
everywhere you know
consensually i don't want you getting
arrested
so um i mean that's interesting you're a
asian guy that got divorced
who did you marry
uh a hispanic chick
wow
you are from texas
um was it because she cooked her rice
different
[Laughter]
it was too dry
we like that wet rice rice is good
that's just good
that was because um
no we were we were dating at a uh
college and um
i ended up getting her pregnant
and uh
yeah that happens with mexican chicks i
want i want i
wanna so so we ended up getting married
but things didn't work out
no he aborted
her he aborted it two years ago when she
was five
the asian way you know just
leave it in the forest
oh god
so you have a seven-year-old daughter
you're co-parenting
that's wonderful
what do you think remo does this warm
your hearts that he's so nurturing
i'm like one year out of college i don't
need the kids thing yet
she is a kid don't have kids they're
expensive
she's 16. you want to adopt her
you can have her look after your
seven-year-old i'll be the next blake
and be a dad
blake
blade yeah yeah somebody called him a
dad
or or no uh
oh yeah
okay thanks for the call back
wow
so
you have a you have a child remo is a
child she just graduated from
college
and now she's working for michael
bloomberg
uh
so uh what do you think what is uh what
is your dating history been like
yikes
have you guys you know her ex
what do you think that your friends
think about your ex
clearly not great
what do i think what do you what do you
think about your ex
it's all right
at least you don't have a kid together
like this loser
you just hit it and quit it
the american way
are your parents pretty traditional or
uh are they more like puja's parents and
don't give a [ __ ] about what you do
they're more like puja's parents
what's with all these cool indian
parents
these cool asian back there
yeah my uh my mom grew up there so we go
back like every other year to see my
grandparents and flaunt
like i'm in america [ __ ] we got the
real trump here
you guys got that fake ass trump
uh so yeah you uh
you go back to india um do you uh you
like it there you speak hindi you
do the diwali festival of colors or
lights or whatever
lights
well i'm a pretty bad indian i don't
don't speak in the hey me too i'm a
terrible indian
i go back and i just kind of chill uh
nice yeah it's not my favorite place
they think you're meditating
you do a lot of drugs i heard uh they
have good weed there the hindu kush
yeah it's the hash there yeah
oh hash
it's uh the part of inyo i'm from though
it's a
it's a dry state so we always have to
meet someone on like the side of the
road in some alley to get like alcohol
or weed and hookah and all that oh my
god
that sucks
and uh and here over here in america we
just have to call tanya and she gives us
all the drugs that we need
uh asian jay what kind of drugs have you
done
remember the cps is watching
no comment no comment what a tea totaler
he's boring
um but yeah you guys could do drugs
together you guys look like a wonderful
couple give it up for uh remo and asian
jay
let's get one more couple up here you
guys ready for one more couple
what [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
hey bert hey how's it going megan
it's going great how are you not bad
yeah i just flew in from moss to austin
yesterday all right i just flew in on
friday nice where are you from i'm from
l.a how about you i'm from chicago nice
yeah
i know
from the suburbs though not that
exciting cool cool how you uh enjoying
your stay in austin you know it's good
you can meet my sister she's right over
there so meet in the family on day one
of cool how fun i know
yeah yeah yeah i'm just hanging out you
know doing some comedy you know hang out
with some friends oh you also do comedy
i do wow i'm actually going to be on at
eight o'clock if you want to stick
around
maybe
[Laughter]
i am wildly hungover today so the fact
that we made it here
was a blessing nice that makes the both
of us
what'd you do
uh i drank a [ __ ] ton of beers i'm full
from popcorn right now all right
oh yeah i also drank a [ __ ] ton of beers
yesterday well let's keep it going
maybe
we'll see i got an early flight to catch
tomorrow morning oh no i know heading
back home there goes my one-night stand
and time
give it up for megan n and
bert hung
everyone's flying out tomorrow
on this show because it's a long weekend
everybody took a weekend trip nice good
to know the inner workings of the
calendar i had no idea i do comedy it's
every day's a weekend for me
uh you're from chicago you brought your
sister on your date are you by a chance
more than i brought my best friend too
so
wow it looks like you're in for a
foursome bert
[ __ ] yes bert
have you ever had a threesome no but i
would jump straight to a foursome no
problem dude
bert have you ever had a twosome
i am ashamed of the ass that hans shame
on you
shame on me of course i hooked up with a
twosome with a twosome yes yes hookers
are cheap these days oh no bert
you're not making us look good
um you're uh you do comedy you're
hungover
uh you uh you invited her to a show at
eight you're plugging another show on
this show it starts in like
20 minutes yeah yeah is it here it's
gonna be right here oh wow look at that
how convenient you get another beer it's
on me i think can my sister and friends
stay too
free drinks damn are you sure you're not
the tech salesman
we got uh [ __ ]
asian jay
he sells parts of his body
interesting
okay
um
so why are you hungover miranda
miranda what did you really liked
miranda wherever she's at miranda you
were great
um why am i hungover well we went and
got a bottle of wine and then a bunch of
margaritas
and where'd we go shangri-la shangri-la
stranger lawn east and
then ordered a domino's pizza and now
you can
visit
domino's pizza that gets an applause
yeah
what the [ __ ] from the new jersey table
i thought you guys had better taste in
pizza than that you [ __ ] sellouts
you're probably from connecticut
you were at shangri-la yesterday and you
could visit shangri-la tonight with bert
hung
no i know
amen again we have so much in common
honestly i'm saving this relationship
um
uh anal how far into the relation wait
wait you didn't let me finish
you don't need to
pre-marriage post-marriage it's
different you're
do you think you could be swayed
no
i am open to ano yes
me and bert no longer have things in
common
i've done
have you heard of grapefruiting anybody
enlighten me i learned about this last
night at the bar
and it's weird
you cut the navels off both sides of the
grapefruit and then cut a hole in the
middle of the grapefruit and put it on a
guy's dick and give them a [ __ ] yeah
that's all while it's on there i never
heard of it and everybody thought it was
weird but bert you seemed like you would
maybe be into that if you like you know
i don't know so that's what it's called
okay
just been doing it for the love of the
game
i just never had a name for it you know
yeah
so you'd never do anal huh i'm gonna
take a hard pass on that one okay it's
sort of the dance of our people as
millennials yeah i'll be easy you know
the asian average you know it's not
going to be very oh my god bert
you are so asian you're like too
self-effacing you got to be more
american just be like my dick's huge
girl i'm just trying to sway her man i'm
just trying so we were there's no
swaying
asian average
that's so sad
uh megan have you ever been with an
asian man before i have not
wow
well tonight's the first
we have a green room you guys can go
back there tell us what it's like
are you married no okay thank god
this is why my sister put my name in the
bucket
your sister put your name in the bucket
yeah she's super sweet
go [ __ ] this asian dude
getting jiggy with it
yeah bird um so what's your dating
history been like
it's been pretty dry i've been uh pretty
single since covet started so pretty
single yeah yeah it's been pretty sad
so you've had a few here and there
uh by here and there you mean hookers
yes
oh my god
i would recommend on a date to uh keep
the hooker talk to a minimum
bert loves the hookers
yeah
he supports the small businesses
uh
megan
what is your history with hookers like
you know i've been to a strip club
before but i have never been with a
hooker ever appealed to me
having fun and feeling good yeah yeah i
hate having fun i hate it no you seem
like a very fun person you don't seem
like you need weed you you seem very
vibrant and joyous oh wow you're so
sweet thanks
uh
yeah this is this is if i was bert this
is where i'd mention the hookers
uh well i mean i think you maybe should
date megan not me
uh bert what is the manliest thing that
you've done during the pandemic
i uh probably just uh
i probably lifted some weight and
dripped off by myself
wow
what a man
he's lifted weights and jerked off
[Laughter]
all that testosterone flowing through
you
so megan
you ever lift weights or
trigger
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah that's exactly the same thing i did
all throughout the pandemic you know hey
it's been a long pandemic
it's hard not to lift something and then
express yourself
um
but uh yeah you're from chicago
uh what do you think about these new
jersey folks that they're great their
pizza is better than yours well i don't
order domino's pizza like regularly
that's not my like claim to fame but we
were hungry and drunk and it was going
to be fast
yeah
speaking of i know i just set myself up
for that
i was surprised you didn't say something
about hookers but speaking of hungry and
fun and fast let me introduce you to
bert hung
we'll get some hoboken after this hop
with that
i ate before i came here
i think it was a hooker talk dude i
don't
i think that filled her right up
she's not hungry at all anymore for some
reason there's a wonderful food truck
here you ever uh you you eat at terry
blacks or check out the local uh
restaurant scene here in austin i mean i
have i've been here a handful of times
oh you like it here i do like it here
chicago is pretty close it's like
directly north right it's just a nice
two and a half hour plane ride yeah so
uh what do you like about austin
um
[Music]
the beer the music
walking around that my sister lives here
oh we get along better now that we don't
live near each other
yeah
am i wrong
so i get to come visit and she just had
a babies and i have a nephew here too
nice yeah
she you had a baby that's awesome
exactly
yeah
um their your pale skin was made for
north face jackets
something like that i guess
i don't actually own one
oh bert maybe you could uh i'm okay
are you gonna give me your jacket this
is a mammoth but yeah it's pretty close
mammoth north face
so yeah i mean uh you you recently had a
baby maybe uh asian jay could tell you
to divorce your uh husband and raise
your kid on your own because that's what
he's doing
[Music]
megan um
what uh what do you think about uh
bert you're chinese
i'm taiwanese actually oh yeah taiwanese
pretty much the same thing
but uh not yet
not yet
what do you think about uh
the the country of taiwan and the this
fine specimen of men that come from
there i know
absolutely zero things about taiwan
we got stinky tofu i think it's
something you should try
that's what they call their hookers
their stinky tofu
i think i'll pass on that
what do you think about this couple this
uh
taiwanese
chicago couple
um they'd be i think they'd be great
babysitters for the little nephew
i think that could go over well
yeah she wouldn't introduce the baby to
any drugs
i would not look at how perfect
yeah
you're like uh
trained your whole life to be a
babysitter i am a teacher
oh you're a teacher planning or
something yeah
that's awesome
that's awesome uh bert what do you do
for a living i'm actually an accountant
whoa
[Laughter]
you guys are made for each other
you could uh you could have him visit
your students and teach them how to
budget
for hookers
[Laughter]
all right give it up for burt and megan
that was the show thank you guys so much
for coming maurice what did you think
about the couples tonight
uh i love interracial couples i'm so
glad y'all are here we had all
interracial couples except for uh you
know uh
blake and
miranda
so that was that was cool we had a bunch
of interracial couples
um
that was fun uh who do you think has the
best chance for uh making it to the next
level
um
i'd say g and nick
she and nick
that was a really interesting dynamic
nick is white and you know how oh she
actually dated three caucasians as she
calls them one more you know yeah the
fourth caucasian in the mix
um you can check out mars g uh she's
doing shows all over town she's on
instagram and facebook and twitter uh
any anything you want to plug
um
yeah you can find me instagram twitter
mxx
a t a p
wow i think that's our password
um yeah no nothing else
mars g give it up for mars give it up
for yourselves thank you guys so much
for coming out please come again
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for coming we also have a show
that starts at 8 o'clock and you can all
stay for free if you would like that and
keep drinking and stuff thank you for
coming
[Music]